Did,
these are dark musings and I would say how much of the antipathy towards man
that's being generated by say college age women is,
uh,
deep repugnance for the role that they've been designed and a disappointment
with the man who,
you know,
like you think of those,
is it Carpathian um,
are,
uh,
um,
I can't remember the culture that the basic Marit marital written routine was to
ride into the village and grabbed the Bryden runaway with her on a horse.
Right.
It's like the,
like the motorcycle gang member who rips the too naive woman out of girl,
out of the bosom of her family,
right?
Say by women.
That's all I can think of.
Ancient myth.
Yeah.
There used to be bride stealing.
It was quite,
quite,
quite widespread.
Right.
Well.
So I kind of wonder if part of the reason that modern university age women
aren't so aren't so angry is because that fundamental feminine role is actually
being denied to them.
And they're,
they're objecting to that at a really,
really fundamental level,
like a level of,
of primitive outrage at,
well,
what's happened is the chaos that my generation of the any sixties be creased
through the sexual revolution.
I went when I arrived in college and I need 64,
right?
W w the colleges were still acting in local parentes in place of a parent.
So my dormitory,
um,
all women's dormitory,
uh,
we,
women had to sign in at 11 o'clock at night.
The men could run free the entire night.
So it was my generation of women that rose up and said,
give us the same freedom as men have.
And the college's replied,
no.
Um,
in the world is dangerous that you could be raped,
a,
we have to protect you against.
Right.
And would we said,
okay,
was give us the freedom to risk rate.
Okay.
So that what?
That today's women don't understand.
It's a freedom that you want.
It's the same freedom that give gay men have when they go and they pick up a
stranger someplace.
They know it's dangerous.
They know that they could end up beaten up or killed.
Okay.
But they find it hat if you want freedom,
if you want equality,
okay,
then you have to stop behaving like a man.
No.
So what we did is we gave freedom to these young women for several generations,
but my generation had been raised and I far more resilient and robust culture.
Okay.
We had the strength,
okay.
To know what we wanted and to fight for what we wanted.
These young women had been raised in this protective terribly protected ways.
Right.
So I think in some strange th you know,
the fashion that,
that all of these demands for intrusion from these,
you know,
Stalinist committees,
sexual,
you know,
investigating dates and so on.
It's a way to re institute,
okay.
The rules that my generation through out the window and I,
so I think these young women are desperate now.
Only that,
but I have spoken out very strongly in,
you know,
ended up in a piece I wrote for Time magazine isn't my most recent book
[inaudible] the racing,
the drinking age in this country.
Okay.
From 18 to 21 okay.
Has had a direct result.
Okay.
In these,
in these disasters of binge drinking fraternity parties because they tend to
elect couch students the way we could go out at as freshmen have a beer,
sit any protected adult environment,
learn how to have discourse with the opposite sex in,
in,
in a safe environment.
Right.
And so on.
And you and not today.
Okay.
Because because of the stupid rule that the young people can't even buy a drink.
You know,
in a bar until the 21 we have these,
the fraternity parties that aren't,
that are like the caveman era.
Well,
of course in,
in this modern age,
this is an advantage as men,
gay men want to hook up and then want to have sex.
Women don't understand what men want.
Women,
women are like put out because they're hoping that maybe the man will continue
to be interested in them.
Okay.
The man just wants experience.
And that the hormones drive toward door to me.
I,
I've,
I've theorized okay.
That the,
you know,
the,
that the sex drive and men is intertwined with,
with hunted pursuits.
Okay.
I feel absolutely,
this is what women don't understand.
Okay.
If women understood what I understand from my transgender perspective,
all right.
These women on the streets,
okay.
I know I'm obviously,
you know,
Madonna and admirer and you know,
and I,
I support pornography and prostitution,
so I don't want what I'm about to save to seem conservative and then it isn't,
okay.
What I'm saying is the women on the street,
young women,
okay.
Who are,
who are jogging.
Okay.
With no bra on.
Short shorts and have and have earbuds in their ears.
Okay.
Just jogging along line.
And I saw these women do not understand the nature of the human mind.
They do not understand the nature of psychosis.
Okay.
And this intertwining them talking about the hunt,
the hunt and pursuit thing.
Okay.
They're triggering a hunter thing.
Just what do what you have talked about in terms of the zebra heard.
Okay.
They are triggering the hunt game,
uh,
impulse.
Okay.
In psychotic men.
I have here the,
there goes a very appetizing and,
and totally oblivious animal.
Okay.
Bouncing along here.
Okay,
sorry.
And we're,
we're in a period now where psychosis is not understood at all.
Okay.
Do you know yet,
young women have,
you had to have had no exposure to movies like psycho.
Okay.
The,
you know,
the kind of rapists serial murderer thing and so on,
the kind of strange dynamic that has to do with the,
with the assault on the,
on the mother and Mongo,
you know,
in,
in the,
in the mind of the psychotic.
But I think that's an incredible naivete.
These young women are emerging and going to college and in this like incredible
Dinesen environment of,
you know,
a,
a sec orgiastic sexual experience in fraternity houses,
they're completely unprepared for it,
right?
And,
and so you're getting all this outrage.
So feminist rhetoric has gotten more and more extreme in its portrayal of men is
evil.
But in fact,
okay,
wait,
what we have is a cask is a,
is a chaos in the sexual realm.
The girls have not been told anything real.
I mean,
in terms of biological substrate,
them just sexual
what constitutes consent
to.
Exactly.
And it's become something that's essentially portrayed linguistically as a
sequence of progressive contracts,
which you know,
is,
it's,
well I think,
you know,
I've thought for a while that we're living in the delusional fantasy of a naive
13 year old girl that's basically sums up our culture.
And I look at all these sexual rules that permeate the,
the,
the academia and I think two things.
The first thing I think as well,
I know because I was an alcohol researcher for a long time,
and you know that 50% of violent crimes are directly attributable to alcohol.
So if you're a murdered,
there's about a 50% chance that you're drunk and about a 50% chance that the
person who kills you is drunk.
And the alcohol is the only drug that we know that actually amplifies
aggression.
It does that in laboratory situations.
Plus it's a great disinhibitor.
Right.
So what alcohol does is it,
it doesn't make you oblivious to the future consequences of your action because
if you ask someone who's drunk about the consequences of something stupid,
they can tell you what the consequences are,
but it makes you not care.
And it does that because it's technically an anxiety alytic like,
like,
like barbiturates are like benzodiazepines.
And it also has a,
as a,
an activating,
um,
uh,
property for many people who drink.
So it's,
it's a stimulant and a,
and an exile lytic at the same time and a very,
very potent,
very potent for both of them.
And,
you know,
we put young people together and douse them in alcohol right at the binge
drinking level.
And then,
which also interferes with memory consolidation,
which of course makes things much more complex.
And then we're surprised when there are sexual misadventures and you know,
and then it's also attributed almost purely to the predatory element that's,
that's,
uh,
part and parcel of masculinity.
But a true,
a tremendous amount of that is also naivety and stupidity.
You know,
because we expect like eight to 18 year old guys,
especially the ones that aren't,
that haven't been successful with girls,
which is like 85% of them because the successful men are a very small percentage
of men.
The 85% who haven't been successful with men or with women,
they don't know what the hell they're doing at all.
Right.
In part of the reason they're getting drunk is to garner up enough courage to
actually make an advance.
Yeah,
because I think another thing that women don't understand,
especially with regards to young men is just exactly how petrifying a attractive
woman whose of say somewhat higher status actually is to a young guy on it.
There's lots of guys that right knee constantly and people that I've worked with
that are so terrified of women,
they can't even talk to them.
It's very,
very common.
Well,
I take a very firm position,
which is that I want college administration,
so stay totally out of the social lives of the students.
If a crime is committed,
it should be reported to the police.
I've been writing now for 2050 of 25 years now.
All right.
But,
but there's not the business of any college administration to take any notice of
what the students say to each other,
say to each other as well as do with each other.
Okay.
I want it to totally stop.
Is Fascism of the work?
Agree
while it's sitting?
It's think it's fascism of the worst time because it's an,
it's a new kind of fascism,
you know,
it's,
it's partly generated by legislation.
So the,
like the title nine men memo that was written in 2011 I recently got a copy of
that God damn thing.
That was one polluting bit of legislation.
That was,
that memo basically told universities that unless they set up a parallel court
system,
they were going to be denied central funding.
It is absolutely unbelievable.
Incredible.
And,
and,
and w in the law,
the leftists are supporting this.
I know,
I know.
It's just this,
and this show is,
there is no authentic campus.
Leftism I'm sorry.
It's a fraud.
Okay.
You think the faculty should be fighting the administration,
federal in federal regulation of,
of you know how we're supposed to behave on camp?
Well,
how can you be so how can you be so naive and foolish to think that taking on an
organization like the university,
which already has plenty to do and you sing it to become a pseudo legal system
that parallels the legal system,
could possibly be anything but utterly catastrophic.
It would mean you'd have to know absolutely nothing about the legal system and
about the tremendous period of evolution that produced what's actually a stellar
system and an adversarial system that protects the rights of the accused and of
the end of the victim.
And to replace that with an ad hoc bureaucracy that has pretty much essentially
the same degree of power as the court system with absolutely none of the
training and none of the guarantees.
Yeah.
And won't get real cards or kangaroo.
That piece that I wrote about date rape,
it was in January,
1991 a news day.
God,
whether the most controversial thing I ever wrote in my entire career,
I attack the entire thing.
And I demand of the college's standing back and get out of the social wise with
the students.
So on and and people that will,
the abreaction people tried to recall it and they called the president of the,
my university tried to get me fired.
You can believe the hysteria.
Okay.
All right.
I can believe it.
Yeah,
it,
yeah.
It won't cost them
anything and it went,
if anything that says to women,
okay,
but they should be responsible for their own choices is regarded as reactionary.
Are they kidding me?
Okay.
This is such a betrayal of authentic feminism in my view.
Well,
it's the ultimate betrayal of authentic feminism because it's,
it's an invitation of all the things that you might be paranoid about with
regards to the patriarchy back into your life.
Right.
It's an insistence that the most intrusive part of the tie radical king come and
take control over the most intimate details of your life.
Incredible.
On the assumption is that that's going to make your life better rather than
worse.
Right.
In that dimension,
this idea of,
you know,
this is the stages of verbal consent.
As if,
as if your impulse is based in the body,
have anything to do with word,
right?
That's the whole point is,
you know,
you're allowed the case to abandon,
okay.
That you know that part of the brain that's so it traveled with words.
I mean there's,
you see
these two actually a marker of lack of social ability to have to do that.
Because if you're a sophisticated,
it's normally like if you're dancing with someone,
it's not like you call out the moves,
right?
If you have to do that,
well then you're,
you're,
you're more worse than a neophyte,
right?
You're an awkward Neil fight and anybody with any sense should get the hell away
from you.
And so if you're reduced to the point where you have to verbally negotiate every
element of,
of intimate interaction,
then what a Downer that he the ass.
But what I want an unbelievably,
what would you call it?
Naive and pathological view of the manner in which human beings interact.